Rome fell in the year for 76.
The microphone wasn't invented
until the 1870s. That's quite a gap.
And yet we still know how the old Romans
pronounced their Latin. Prove it. Okay.
Catholic school literature
class. My teacher, his father,
let's call him father f a
fellow language had himself,
father f has a much fuller
experience bar than me.
Respect it's first thing in the morning
and that schoolrooms sunlight is barely
starting to flip. The activation
switches in my brain language.
The words drift in from across the class.
Consonants.
Italian pronunciation up goes my sensor.
One kids over there talking
with the father best I can
recall it went like this.
So, um, how do we know what
Latin sounded like? I mean,
I always thought Caesar's quote was
Venae [inaudible] but some Latin student
told me V's were W's and
sees where Kay's Ha, oh,
come on.
Can you imagine any good Italian
saying where any Wiki Wiki.
Uh, I'm sitting there. Sure.
This is wrong. Somehow. See,
my first linguistic obsession was reading
up on how Latin became the romance
languages. So why was I
suddenly speechless? Lee
Tongue tied. Well, young self,
it took me years,
but I'm back to help.
We think we know it's Caesar's Latin
sounded like and that wasn't it.
We know because well sometimes they
told us quintillion was a smart guy from
Roman Spain who moved to Rome,
managed to survive the off the wall year
of the four emperors and then founded a
school of rhetoric also.
He hated the letter k,
so k I think shouldn't be
used at all the letters.
C keeps it strength before all the vowels.
If he's saying see,
always made a k sound,
that means it didn't have that second
soft pronunciation it does in English or
Italian,
but that's one grew Marian say so
things could look different when all the
evidence comes in,
which is exactly what one check linguist
claims about the letter r your Latin
textbooks says it's a real,
she argues it's a tap edit.
We're just going to have to piece
together the evidence ourselves.
Starting with ancient authors
writing in good Latin.
The first clue they give us
is the alphabet, which was
meant to fit Latin sounds.
You hear that English.
So when they wrote words differently,
like on those unknowns and unknown,
it's a face value hint that they said
them differently, meaning that long, ah,
which sometimes has this little apex
doesn't sound the same as short up and
double consonants don't sound like
single consonants in the hands of Virgil,
the epic poet, that CNC Alphabet
is jammed into a precise structure,
poetic meter.
From that meter we can figure out which
syllables are long in which are short,
which helps confirm which valves are long
and which ones are short. So some eyes,
sorry, eas are longer than other
eas, but go look for short.
He on inscriptions and you'll
find something interesting
or won't find because
it might be representing an a why.
Well,
it makes sense if short he wasn't only
shorter than long e but it also had a
different sound, a sound
closer to a uh, kind of,
eh Romans left even more clues when
they marched right into foreign language
territory then got raided by
Germanic tribes, linguistic rates.
We're all taking words guys, what do
you want oil? Bring me back from wine.
I want a wall.
Yup.
Those are Latin words and bad accents
and they make it look like versus where
was at the time something we'd already
be suspicious of from poetry and word
pairs. So yes, good Latin
was spreading the back home.
The Roman rebel was busy turning it bad.
Good Latin writers notice though and
even included characters speaking the bad
Latin, the sediment will goddess,
especially for a good laugh,
but bad Latin can still be good evidence
down in palm pay before the tragedy,
a random guy comes along and is the place
to make sure we'd forever know that he
stopped here with his brother.
He does something vulgar though.
He drops the h in the word here.
Ah,
just a little mistake right
later you find a very dusty,
very old book full of cranky corrections
telling you that the word for old is
wet,
too loose,
not wet clothes to say [inaudible]
not [inaudible] and [inaudible] Mata.
Not No matter. Come on,
people get it together.
It looks like the pump papers weren't
the only ones dropping their ages.
These mistakes are an interesting
kind of proof. I mean,
you probably wouldn't beg me to stop
dropping my ages and less people were
indeed dropping their ages.
But what was once linguistic heresy
eventually turned into romance languages?
These all have something to
teach us about Latin. Wait,
how can new languages be
evidence for a dead one?
We'll take Spanish or Italian a,
it comes from Latin a but it
also comes from short, eh,
but not long.
He kind of like those inscriptions.
It's even more evidence for
short versus long. Also see,
not know the letter c,
the romance languages still love it,
but before ease and eyes, it makes
us soft sound except in Sardinian.
So we'll good Italian. Say Vincenti
in Sardinian conquering is bean cafe.
No Romance Palatalization
is another story,
but historical linguistic says these
languages are whispering at us and see,
always sounded like Kay,
but most of us changed their thumbs.
Upping quintillion.
So you see younger self,
all of this is why when Romans
talked about conquering,
they said when Katee and why Caesar's
phrase was Winnie weedy Wiki.
Now before you go around in forcing
reconstructed pronunciation on us,
getting the pope to speak like a real
Caesar. Think about Latins living history.
This was, but one part of the
story. Pretty amazing one though.
Stick around and subscribe for language.